hi my name is galiona I'll be presenting
our paper decision making under
miscalibration this is Joint work with
guy Rathbone and unfortunately I
couldn't be here in person so apologies
in advance
okay so the setting we study in this
work we call it from predictions to
Decisions by predictions I mean that we
have an individuals a universe of
individuals X and some risk predictor
which is a mapping from X to values in
the interval zero one for example to
estimate the risk of a cardiovascular
event in some follow-up period by
decisions I mean that the way we intend
to use B is to inform multiple
Downstream binary decision problems for
example whether an individual should be
prescribed a medication or be given a
certain medical treatment
so we treat this in a utility-based
framework basically we assume we have
some distribution over individual and
outcome pairs a risk predictor as I
mentioned a treatment threshold is just
some number J in the interval 0 1 where
we understand that someone receives a
treatment if their prediction is higher
than this value and a downstream
decision problem is basically
parameterized by its cost structure so
think of it as the relative costs of
making correct versus incorrect
predictions so overall all of these
components Define a utility from
threshold in P at a threshold J
and we will say that the treatment is
harmful if this utility is actually
lower than what we could have obtained
without having used the predictor at all
right we can always just decide to treat
everyone or treat no one and that gives
us some sense of utility as well
okay so for us the decision making
problem is basically given the cost the
distribution and the predictor how
should we choose the treatment threshold
J
and an existing but partial answer to
this question is that whenever the
predictor is perfectly calibrated then
there is a threshold but I'll notice J
star and in the literature is known as
the therapeutic threshold which
guarantees no harm in this case
and the interesting property about J
star is that it does not depend on
either the distribution or the predictor
at all only on the cost structure of the
decision problem
and here is the perfect calibration
requirement is basically saying that for
every possible risk value V if we look
at all the individuals that receive the
prediction of Z exactly the fraction of
these actually have positive outcomes in
the true distribution
um unfortunately this result breaks down
under miscalibration so for example in
this previous work the authors used
simulation studies to show that whenever
they induce miscalibration to a
calibrated predictor P eventually it
makes treating at this therapeutic
threshold are actually harmful in the
sense that I've defined before
so let's start gaining some intuition
for how decision making might look like
under miscalibration so supposedly the
therapeutic threshold here is 0.05
intuitively this means that I anticipate
a much greater benefit from identifying
true positives than having false
positive predictions
and consider the say the subset of women
who receive a prediction of 0.04
should I treat these or should I not
treat these so if I knew that my
predictor was perfectly calibrated on
this subgroup then I know that I should
not treat them but what happens under
miscalibration so I could still use J
star and not read them but then if my
predictor was underestimating the risk
in this population I might regret not
treating them but on the other hand if I
use a lower threshold and then find out
that my predictor was overestimating the
risk in this group then I might regret
treating them so overall we have these
competing concerns and it's not a priori
clear how to balance them because the
impact of the errors that I can have
within a certain bound of a
miscalibration errors don't have
symmetric effects because of the kind of
asymmetric nature of this binary
decision problem
so a work is motivated precisely by this
question of how do our decisions impact
protected groups and there's actually a
lot of work showing that this is really
an issue in practice for example this
work uh discusses how the commonly used
farming harmless score for
cardiovascular risk overestimates the
risk in women which indeed causes a
harmful model if you use it for
thresholds 20 or higher
and you might ask okay maybe what we
need to do is we need to just upfront
ensure that our predictor is
multi-calibrated well this is important
but it doesn't completely solve the
problem because as long as we have a
finite number of samples and a rich
Class C where we can bound the worst
case calibration error there are still
going to be some calibration errors that
are just inevitable so we don't skip
this problem completely
so the perspective that we put forth in
this work is basically if J star the
therapeutic threshold is the optimal
threshold to allow to apply to a
perfectly calibrated predictor
irrespective of the distribution and the
predictor is there a similarly optimal
threshold that we should be applying
when we're faced with an imperfectly
calibrated predictable
and while this kind of compiles it does
suggest several natural questions most
importantly which solution concept
should be used to determine optimality
here and then what is this threshold end
up looking and is it actually different
from J star
so I'll give an overview of our results
basically to determine the solution
concept we Define a notion of regret
under bounded miscalibration and we
propose that you should use a threshold
that is Minimax optimal that minimizes
the maximal regret that you can obtain
um technically we show that you can
actually obtain closed form expressions
for this threshold under different ways
of measuring miscalibration these end up
having very simple expressions
and these reveal that this threshold
actually ends up being different from J
star precisely for decision problems
that have very asymmetric costs in some
sense this gives uh formal and rigorous
explanation for a behavior that's
actually quite intuitive which is if
you're under uncertainty because of the
miscalibration and the problem is
asymmetric then in some sense you should
be conservative
so to summarize we showed that uh even
slight miscalibration might require you
to take this miscalibration into account
and change how you translate predictions
to decisions
our solution concept is just one choice
it's very worst case in in nature and I
think an interesting question for
follow-up work is whether by building an
additional assumption the effective
miscalibration ends up being maybe
different in interesting ways and I
think more broadly thinking of
algorithmic decision making not as a one
component but as a pipeline problem is
interesting because it opens up this
question of how do the different stages
impact each other for example maybe it's
just useful etc for the earlier stages
like we did here with multi-calibration
but maybe it suggests that we should
have a different behavior for the
subsequent stages depending on what we
anticipate when prong in the beginning
of the pipeline
um that's it thank you very much for
your attention and happy to discuss
offline thanks